hello everybody excuse me hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to Walden and the werewolf
sorry for the gap from this episode the
last one I was very busy with the weird
bed didn't you don't care about any of
that let's just get into it I'm hoping
there aren't gonna be any more problems
coming up the mysterious being tricked
Walden to get him poison but Walden
healed himself with a medicine already
couldn't believe he was being attacked
by a giant snake his vision was blurry
but his revenge was just beginning okay
then if you say so so anyway now that I
have the ability to speak we're back in
the game again and I'm ready to go
nice music anyway oh it's a horsey again
I remember what happened last time when
I encountered you oh there's more ammo
in here almost missed that I would have
been very easy to missed am I about to
shoot a werewolf now am I gonna fight II
fight a little guy I don't understand
how I got poisoned the snake never
exactly bit me and I collected its tooth
maybe just touching it would cause me to
be ooh
I know that sounds relaxing but in this
context it's a little disturbing so how
much you don't owe with all the dead
bodies the sound of a little child
singing not so friendly not so nice with
the beer aha a key oh okay I'm my vision
is still a little blurry but then again
that's what that guy said so I need to
get my revenge for poisoning myself by
grabbing on to the tooth of him what was
that what [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh I was
very friendly or nice how about you go
everyw stuff oh god this game certainly
likes to get you when you least expect
it oh good I got a key to the head high
fence I could have easily jumped over
what do you do new new what don't tell
me there was something up there I was
coming down oh yeah you what you're
going up them oh hey what
I'm a little confused you can't kill
this creature but you can slow
high-pressure what crazier Oh in front
of me where is it oh I am your bra ah I
gotta reload up oh I think I died oh
come on how is that even a little bit
fair oh that's my body okay I'm dead
well is it I love how my hat just landed
directly on my face good for me okay can
I can I not be dead
please come on
all right
okay so the things gonna appear in front
of me this time and I'm definitely gonna
be able to shoot it so I need to like
get to one side and shoot it where's
there you're okay I got to slow it down
to get around it
how am I gonna do that okay ha okay I
see you limping whoa where you go where
you going where to go where to go where
to go ah nope okay got ya now I'm gonna
go this way
turn around where to go where to go
where to go oh come on oh did I kill it
or did I stop it from hitting me no no
no
no no here we go going the right way
okay
yeah yeah okay it's always gonna appear
in front of me apparently
you know where are you where are ya no
no you buy me Barry where are you
ah I do it I like how you bleed green
blood that's awfully nice of you
come on are you
almost there come on just hold it
together come on
I got you [ __ ] I got your number come
on come on come on come on go on ha ha
King yell go back up back up back up
back up back up I see you BAM [ __ ] oh
you need a few more shots well I got a
few more shots for you I right on you
baby
oh one more oh come on come on come on
no no no no no no no no no come on
reload faster reload faster Wow
yeah [ __ ] that down how'd you like the
taste it was good no just good I like
how it disappears into a moon that's
awfully nice isn't even night I can't
tell I've never been out during green
hour hey did I make it there gonna be
one more did I make it did I make it did
I make it think I made it good I make it
Oh bridge oh that's nice
ok look across the bridge
don't break like the other bridge I can
tell you got so many support Sonia
that I steer and I'm gonna move oh you
on another one I got another one thank
you for being in a state line for me to
shoot the [ __ ] out them get one more one
more come on oh wait a minute what we
run that by me again
what happened where'd you go
did I leave the bridge and he
disappeared I don't forget right I'm
don't seem right what god damn it again
don't do that to me don't do that to me
don't do that to me mud come on don't do
that to my lovely viewers I feel yeah
yeah we want another one
Oh where'd you go BAM right in the head
oh no I didn't get you are you stuck
you better be stuck good you stay right
there buddy
burski aw come on
I swear I'm hitting it oh come on what
the hell
don't tell me that I can't hit it from
here goddamn it goddamn it
what's the deal there we go okay she's
got a hit in Sarma I don't have enough
bullets left okay gotta hit it hard
there we go no no no no you get out of
here you get out of here with that coop
sock come on stay out of here yeah yeah
I only got one bullet left
how am I supposed to do come on shot no
oh come on
everybody's supposed to do what am I
supposed to do
ah come on uh-huh I came so far what the
hell
what the hell is going on what is this
bull it's gonna get me gonna get me with
this wibbly-wobbly Z I don't have any
bullets last oh come on this such bull
are you stuck if I go by you will you
get me or will you come unstuck
okay can you reason with you you are an
awfully beautiful werewolf the lovely
heart of gold and you'd never ever bite
me right right oh good gonna get me oh
it's gonna get me gonna get me what do I
do
maybe it'll bite me
it's gonna get me oh you're right mother
please
come on I came all that way for nothing
god damn it okay I'll be back in a bit
oh whatever you know whatever
okay I'm back at the bridge now and now
I just need to cross it and kill this
bastard I've got ten boat left I was a
little smarter with how I used them so
this time you ain't gonna get me so good
or not at all preferably not at all
would be good
misty he disappeared before when I
crossed the threshold of the bridge yeah
just like that okay so I've got eight
bullets left I only think he spawns one
more time over there but for some reason
I wasted some bullets trying to hit him
I don't think he can disappear once I
crossed there I just got to get around
him to whatever I'm looking for I think
that
huh thank you for that that was lovely I
really really really appreciate it
right yeah where are you where are you
oh yeah okay I just got trying to get
around them I've done this a few times
already
no no Nana Nana you stay right there
okay come on you I got my eye on you no
you stay where'd you go where'd you go
where are you where are you oh yeah
where is he oh that's him well where am
I okay there we go yeah what am i doing
no no no no no no no no no no no no oh
come on oh my god oh my go
all right ha ha ha good job guys we did
it now I'm gonna keep going just because
there's a lot of stuff that I'm gonna
cut out of the last ones though I know
that there's more time let's get to it
oh now that's it
all right thanks for playing this alpha
3.0 final release date early 2014
they're not bad it was not bad it has
some significant scares in it in huge
huge scares in my opinion but I may be
weak just because I'll play with volume
like way turned up and they were
SuperDuper loud my here's all kind of
weird ha ha yeah either way that was
good I finally got it working I had some
technical difficulties before but either
way it's all good now so thank you all
so much for watching click games next
for more videos that I've done and
that's always I will see you in the next
video
I
oh bugger
Oh
Oh God